if I can play any Marvel V what should I
pick what should I
pick God I was nervous I was excited uh
but look at you which one what guys guys
this is the best interview of hi I'm
Chris Evans and this is my puppy
interview puppy interview where are
these
puppies
are they just going to like come running
in here oh my God see I I have two my
expect I I have to chill because like
I'm expecting like a waterfall of
[Music]
puppies hi guys hi hi hi booy hi hi hi
oh my God you guys are so sweet
oh hey had' to happen I pal
look at that
face
hi
God who
cares uh if I can play any Marvel V what
should I pick what should i p maybe uh
ioki seems to have the most fun come
here guys come
here come here come over here come here
hi hi hi
Buster yeah I did of course I did I love
Toy Story when I was younger hi Buster I
love Toy Story buddy oh man this is a
problem hi Belle hi guys which one what
this is impossible hi belle look at that
face hi hi Buster hi sweet man oh thank
you
[Music]
B who cares
maybe maybe the first one just because
it was the original hi Bubby hi
[Music]
pal I was nervous I was intimidated I
was excited uh
but look at you guys guys come on Come
Get It Go Get
It God oh man this is terrible oh Bubby
hi pal hi pal hi busted br oh my God
he's so
sweet uh I guess Rex Rex would be a good
movie right don't you think that'd be a
good one
[Music]
right I guess it depends on the movie
villains are fun they give give you a
little bit more chance to play hi Hi man
hi Buster Brown
hi uh what's the one question I wish I
got asked God I don't know I can't think
of anything I mean what do you think
Buster what do you think guy hi hi hi hi
guys hi
hi when I was
[Laughter]
younger when I was younger I really
wanted to be an
animator this is the best interview of
my
life hi guys hi guys hi pal look at that
face look at that face
hyp God what's a good song Maybe Return
of the
Mac
[Music]
H to be 48 Hours another Avenger that's
a tough call cuz they're all such good
friends of mine garlett's my girl rener
would be trouble Downey would be a lot
of fun Hemsworth would make me feel bad
about myself I'm not sure they'd all
have some some uh they it's it's it's
it's an impossible question to answer
you got scratch pal come here let me get
it I got
[Music]
you voice acting is it's daunting cuz
you really only have one string to play
on um and and it takes a minute to
realize how how colorful you can be buer
come here pal you guys are so tough
you're all flexing you're showing off
you can't do that come here hi bust hi
Buster
hi about to go home with all these
props
[Music]
well perfect square we were both so
young um and that was back you know when
you just you know it's almost like
summer camp you're just so excited to be
doing what you love to do and it's just
you know you feel like a little adult
going out and having drinks and getting
dinners like you're a grownup by Nanny
Diaries I mean she was really on her way
so I don't know by then it kind of felt
like it was exciting hi Buster come here
look at that mug you look a little
nervous huh it's okay
my
God look at this guy hi Buster hi pal
look at that face and yeah look at you
you little troublemaker you little
troublemaker I don't know what is the
question I mean by then she was like you
know my my sister we were so tight at
that point then it really felt kind of
like we were in our adulthood and really
working on something really meaningful I
bust look at this mug that was
unbelievable but now we're going to
bring in some older
[Music]
dogs my dog Dodger I I I rescued him and
he was though a puppy technically he was
probably 2 years old at the time I
always thought when I adopted a dog or
rescued a dog it would be a little puppy
and Dodger was a full- grown dog and it
wasn't the story I had in my mind but it
ended up being the best decision of my
life so I just think a lot of adult dogs
and older dogs get overlooked and that's
so let's give them some love
too hey hi hi it's okay come here let's
let's build some trust hi pal it's cool
you all right these sweet guys who knows
what their story is I mean some of them
oh guys God it just makes you want to
spend time and earn their trust no
better feeling than earning a dog's
trust is
[Music]
there yeah every morning it's play hi
Buster hi pal oh look you see it's so
sweet I mean they just have such a such
a connection with whoever they've been
around for a while and it makes an older
dog's love so special you got to earn it
no disrespect to the puppies but you
know these guys have probably seen some
things and as a result they're a little
wary it's why it takes time and I really
respect
that he so sweet pal thanks for trusting
me
bubba
[Music]
have
I I don't
[Music]
know probably Downey you know he's seen
a lot been through a lot and he's so
talented he'd be a fool to not listen hi
guy hi guy you are so sweet thanks bud
thanks for trusting
[Music]
me let's cast Adam Driver see what he
does
and who would I cast to play Scott God
that's a good question I don't know I
think only Scott can play Scott little
shout out to uh Pacific pups rescue for
hooking us up with these dogs today
they're all so sweet and they all need
hom so go to a shelter to find your dog
a lot of loving friends waiting for
you excuse you what a good
man good job Bubba those big BS
what's up guys very exciting day today I
am back with BuzzFeed and I am going to
get to sit down with some puppies and
answer some wonderful questions I'm sure
I won't answer any of the questions
because I will be so infatuated by these
wonderful little puppies so I'm very
excited to be back the first person to
be back let's do this please bring me
[Music]
puppies are they going to bring them all
at
once oh
hello hello little puppy oh no it's okay
oh he smells so good hello hello oh
[Music]
hello it was amazing it was incredible
it's a film about exploration so it made
sense to us that we needed to be on
practical locations you know in
Barcelona look at that puppy I wonder
what they think is going on this one is
double cute oh do you want to go play go
play go play what was your
question my favorite stunt in Uncharted
look at these dogs stop it guys this is
beautiful this little one you so you're
like me you're the little one hello I
think this one's my favorite no no no
it's okay I'll protect you come up here
oh little belly scratch what was your
question again what were we talking
about favorite stunt uh there's a stunt
in the movie hello this is a big one
he's going to be a big dog my favorite
stunt to film in
Uncharted oh no careful careful careful
I like the stunt where I fall out the
back of the plane I get hit by the car
that was a lot of fun it was very
nerve-wracking my mom came to see me
that day tickle tickle tickle tickle um
and that was a lot of fun oh wow look
this one is now loving my shoes these
aren my shoes I'm borrowing them so you
can do whatever you want to then mate go
on get in there get in there do you ever
get anything done in these interviews
the first scene we filmed was us in the
Crypt and it was very fun I was very
excited to meet him I've been a big fan
of his for a long time come here puppy
uh and we were good friends and we had a
good time and you know it was one of
those things where we didn't have to
force the chemistry which was really
nice I love the fact that this dog is
chewing on these shoes
luant are they tasty the shoes hello
beautiful my favorite scene to shoot
with Sophia is the scene where she
knocks me out with the gun because it's
one of those things where it really
annoys me in films when people play
unconscious but you can see them like oh
you can see them like catch themselves
as they hit the floor wow these dogs are
ripping these shoes man I can't wait to
send these back to Christian labutin and
be like I'm so sorry it's quite cute as
well their little teeth can't quite get
into
it what would I like to see I'd like to
travel the world some more you know
obviously with this film because of Co
we weren't able to um travel everywhere
we wanted to go so it' be nice to make
another movie and um and just travel
some more you know and get to see the
world and make a movie
and hello puppy oh hello puppy yeah that
would be fun this one just wants to go
to bed you can go to sleep and live with
us in my apartment cuz you are going to
be our
[Music]
puppy if I could do a lip syn B I would
choose I would do a song from tick Tick
boom and impersonate him hello oh I'm
going to lie down with you
o not so much a funny story but um this
dog loves my shoes not so much a funny
story but I do remember um guys guys
guys guys guys just being really felt
feeling really bad about lying to
everyone all the time cuz everyone
really wanted to know and I just was
constantly lying Ling about the fact
that they weren't in the film where are
you going mate this one has stopped
nibbling my shoes and started nibbling
my ankle this is a very cute one he or
she she
she I mean dowy always answers when I
call him Downey probably would answer
hello mate I'm going to go in levels of
cuteness this one is pretty cute maybe
that's what we need guys is a team dog
we're about to shoot a TV show here in
New York for the next s months and maybe
what
we
need is a team do are you okay mate
relax
bro no but I am about to take a puppy
home from this interview no I've taken
loads of props home I steal props all
the time with permission sometimes I
love that they are nibbling on these
shoes how much are these shoes 1,800
bucks get in there guys my stylist lore
is probably having a fit right
[Music]
now I would be in Euphoria I think i'
would be a really good Maddie I'm a big
Euphoria fan I love the show and I love
season 2 I visited a lot while they were
shooting it and I really really enjoyed
it I up again I would love to guest star
or just be an extra in it or maybe I am
you just don't
know careful careful your your mate is
trying to sleep there I haven't actually
I have a background in tap dancing I've
been tap dancing for years so a lot of
that is going to be sort of relearning
stuff I already know but I'm very
excited we're very early stages of
development so I still haven't read a
script yet but it's very exciting but
not as exciting as the fact that this
dog chose me to come home with
[Music]
me I would probably just go and walk
around town and go and visit all the
favorite spots I used to go as a kid and
enjoy which I can't go to anymore
someone made a bad smell and it wasn't
me I can't believe how soft they are
you're a little terror you are he's like
you're all trying to sleep get
up
I think Arvin Russell would probably be
the trickiest one to get along with
please get in there and get comfy that
would be so cute no you're just going to
walk all over him I think Nathan Drake
and Peter Parker would really get along
they're both very adventurous they like
doing the right thing
hey oh there's a shoe there
[Music]
mate I think for me was when BuzzFeed
invited me back ow ow ow ow ow ow
careful which when they invited me back
to do puppies 2.0 we are not going to be
able to give any of these clothes back
there is a hole in my trousers and these
are actually my
[Music]
socks I've got some
amazing that is so cute how is that
comfortable for him on the bottom no
guys
guys I'm so sorry I'll protect you guys
you can go back to sleep I've had some
pretty cool fan art like loads of really
great fan art which has been a lot of
fun some of the fans are so talented and
they do the amazing stuff and it's
really expressionistic and really
different and so I that's the stuff I
really like ow got sharp little teeth
man come and join the cuddle come and
join this
cuddle any book I'd probably have to say
the Harry Potter books like to go back
and read those again was pretty magical
I'd love to go and
rewatch or relive the time I saw
Spider-Man 1 for the first time I I was
very excited obviously it was a big
thing for me to be in that movie and it
was lifechanging so the day that I got
to go and see that was incredibly
exciting hello hello what's what what
you going through what are you going
through What's Happening Here mate this
is the one for me and that is definitely
look at this guy yeah get it get it get
it
a I know we're going to put you up here
so you're out of the way there we go
look they've all left and there's one
final candidate he likes the taste of my
makeup
up oh I know I'm Elizabeth Olen and I'm
here with
BuzzFeed and I'm going to play with
[Music]
puppies
um I don't have a
dog my friends are going to really enjoy
this
[Music]
okay hi there's a lot of
trying this is actually harder than I
thought there's um trying to figure out
like how much of uh me do I want to
bring and how much do I want to stay
true to a character cuz it's not like
I'm playing OJ Simpson you know he's I'm
not playing an iconic character in
history I'm just playing a woman who the
story has been cold a few times um so
I'm just I think it was a balance of
that I did there's only one interview or
anything that might the woman I played
Candy Montgomery she only participated
in
one iming a hole they're just jumping
through the piece of paper and escaping
she only participated in one
interview and it was for this book
evidence of love so I used that as my
Bible was this book because other than
that she chose not to ever do an
interview after the trial and so I
resp
okay okay
sorry this is so funny I really just we
had a really fun cast it was a lot of
fun to spend time with each other so I
guess my favorite memories were us
trying kind of getting to know each
other when we were filming all the
church scenes when we first started
shooting I loved filming in in Austin
it's a very convenient city to live in
which is important when you relocate for
7 months but we've seen every small town
that um is within an hour's Drive
outside of Austin and there's a lot of
very cute I just feel like genitals on
my
[Music]
sorry yeah I think the outfit she
chooses to wear when she's going to
that's so cute they're they're just
teething on my shoe I think it's one of
the oddest outfits that she chose to
wear was what she wore to the police
station for the first time she really
dressed up and I and we never really see
her in Black in the episode and it's the
first time we see her dressed in black
to go to the police station and I
thought that's kind of odd and funny my
least favorite outfit I can say is the
murder outfit cuz I had to be in it for
so long and I got so sick of
it yeah I mean I've had worse blood you
know I've had a lot of other weird stuff
happen to me on camera than that I'm
just always wet and covered in blood and
everything I do I think uhoh here he
goes That's it he discovered how to step
up on those blocks oh he will never
forget it now and they're all going to
learn at the same
time it's like watching Lemmings they're
all just going to start walking off the
cliff this was a very easy thing to
create a playlist for cuz DAV Kelly had
already chosen basically for the most
part all of the music and um I really
didn't like disco before Oh nailed me
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
now I like disco that's all I'm trying
to
[Music]
say yeah I've taken some things this I
took a piece of art we had a really
amazing production designer we had a
little bit of a sale at the end of our
show and I a I took a piece of art from
one of the Gore's
[Music]
bathrooms uh I think my favorite was us
being an Agatha's little dungeon
Catherine and I had to really invent
some stuff there and it was a pretty
beautiful set so I think got just me
being like hanging on a wire being
tortured by her was my favorite part of
that
[Music]
episode yeah I think that I think the um
Thunder oh see there's the Hulk ah we
got a good sound now now I got your
attention you going to leave me now oh
yes the magic shelf he was fabulous in
that and I just really got to watch him
be great and you know be a little show
girl I liked what I got to wear the
Oscars I felt very very pretty in that
[Music]
dress loved it I really I'd never done
anything like that before so it was nice
doing it with someone I know and
[Music]
love I don't know if I miss playing her
but I thought a lot of the writing was
really fun for an actor I kind of like
playing something that doesn't feel feel
like a version of myself and Le felt
like too much of a version of myself so
I'm kind of okay not saying goodbye to
her my husband was already writing
children's books and we had oh you like
the inside of my shirt I see you're a
boy or not you know either way hey you
get over
here that's how my dad would parent dogs
that's what I learned hey you get over
here if everyone speaks
English my husband was writing books and
it was during Co that he and I started
collaborating and an editor who liked
his writing for a different book asked
him to come up with an idea for um the
book about that that help children with
their anxieties my husband within like
30 minutes came up with Hatty Harmony
cuz he's he's got a lot of good ideas
he's like more of the cute writer and
I'm more the like facts and uh structure
so it's really it's actually pretty easy
for us cuz we compliment each other
pretty pretty well and it's I don't
recommend it for everyone I don't
recommend working with your um
significant other uh but I it works out
for
us did you say
WRA oh who's wand going to rap with uh I
guess the new girl I really think is
funny Miss Marvel yeah I think she's
very very cute and endearing and
enjoyable and so I would say
her I watch succession and I watch SNL
and I watch the Dodgers and the Dodger
season just started so that's my current
season I'm obsessed
with I would like to go back and do
something where I could be funnier but
it was it was nice to be there
oh get that on camera my favorite is
just having diarrhea
[Music]
everywhere
I was shocked the moment they told me
what it was about they I was shocked at
the moment they said you're the
villain no one told me until right
before we shot it so that was shocking
hi you want this there you go you want
to join us
now no but I think my goal was to make
sure that nothing seemed like a repeated
Arc I try really hard not to make it
repetitive cuz I think that might not be
fun for fans guys want a p
colada my friend named Charlie damsky
cuz for some reason he likes to FaceTime
a lot and he like we'll FaceTime me at
8:00 in the morning on a Thursday and I
never understand why but he would answer
he's a very talented man though he would
answer my husband not so much he'd be
like call next time I'm not FaceTiming
you
ever I like sketch comedy shows oh we
got another one in the same spot hey hey
hey hey
no anyone else need a poop Now's the
[Music]
Time Candy shockingly enough felt like I
could do no wrong playing her felt very
free in my body davidy Kelly asked me we
were at South by Southwest if I missed
her cuz he knew I did and I said yes and
we both wish it were a fictional story
so we could do a second
season is it obvious I'm not a dog
person well that was me playing with
puppies on BuzzFeed go watch Love and
Death
hello oh hey oh my God you're pre you're
the most precious thing I've ever seen
on my oh my God there's a two you have a
friend hi hi oh my God are you being so
good are you are you being so good this
is the best thing ever hi it's uu and
I'm here with BuzzFeed to answer your
questions while playing with puppies
which is crazy how is that even a thing
that you do anyway bring
them oh my God I can hear them I'm so
excited I'm I'm happy to answer your
question in just one sec oh she going to
okay okay so there the one scene this
one's name is Minnie the scene oh hello
on the airplane we were in the airplane
and then I was trying to explain to her
how to pronounce my name it was that one
and Nora is very funny we had lots of
long takes where we were we were
improvising and and it was really great
and she's a comedic genius and what's
your name where are these puppies come I
have so many
questions my favorite memory working
with Michelle is that she loves to dance
dance in between oh my God she loves to
like dance in between takes she's
honestly such a such a goofball in real
life I feel like she plays a lot of
these really like kind of frigid
intimidating characters and oh hello oh
hello just how like fun she is and Goofy
and warm so I think that's that
definitely my favorite part of working
with her and and also how much she loves
like getting people together for group
dinners cuz I know that's something that
I love doing
too
I would love to interact with corg from
Thor Ragnarok or
like you know one of the ones that don't
get a lot of love oh my God oh my God a
character that doesn't have their own
their own movie it' be like adopting be
like adopting a Marvel character much
like all of these dogs are available for
adoption are they not are they not when
you come home with
me
oh my god oh that's a good question
that's a good question you know I was
pretty Star Struck by Steph K I'm not
going to lie I did manage to muster up
the courage to say hi I was really Star
Struck meeting these guys I definitely
didn't have that reaction is that a
shoelace is that a
shoelace it was a crazy crazy whirlwind
I feel like oh my God I feel like I just
didn't get any sleep but in the best
possible way it was just it was so
incredibly overwhelming but also really
educational everyone on that cast is so
like so incredibly funny there like a
master class it was a master class in
comedy it was a master class in comedy
puppy I forgot the question I feel like
it was that's my shoelace that's my shoe
hey you the first um movie or TV
character that I saw probably like the
Yellow Ranger and the original Power
Rangers which you know ow ow ow ow ow
that's my shin and my shoelace you know
it wasn't it it wasn't subtle it was
like the early 9s version of um
diversity it was like the yellow ranger
was Asian it was pretty cool I remember
how that made me feel it it kind of just
sent a jolt of electricity through me
seeing that for the first time and um it
kind of means the
word that's not a snack that's my shoe
you're silly you silly it's a tremendous
honor just because we didn't have a lot
of that representation when I was when I
was younger so to see kids dressing up
Shi for Halloween being fans and and and
seeing themselves reflected in in in
that way I think is is extremely
meaningful and everyone should have a
dog
you're silly you're silly I did every
stunt that I could have I I fought for a
lot I think a lot of producers on our
movie were very protective of me which
you know I I really appreciated I really
wanted to put my best for forward I
wanted to take ownership over the the
the physicality uh and and the movement
of the character and so I fought to do
as much as I could I would say at the
end probably like 707 5% of the stunts I
was kind of like an on again off against
stunt man working in Toronto before then
um in addition to acting and and I was
kind of like a substitute stunt man
that's my shoe you're so silly that's my
shoe look at all these toys isn't it
funny that dogs always pick the the one
thing that's like not a toy and they
just big on that those are shoes you
silly goose is Silly
Goose
I got to take his Jordan oh god oh ow oh
oh my god oh those are very teethy
there's a lot of teeth in that kiss I
took some shirts I didn't take the
costume the costume itself is it comes
in like three pieces it's actually
really really difficult to to put on and
impossible to do by yourself so it
wouldn't have done me any good to to
take it home but at some point I'll have
the version that's easier to put on whoa
whoa whoa guys guys play
nice
what that's like asking me which one of
these beautiful little creatures I like
the most you can't do that you love them
all equally they're all equally strong
isn't that right oh that's still my
shoelace though we cannot give these
back okay let me just tie these up real
quick my answer is no answer I don't
think any oh oh hello I can't choose I
think I think all of them are equally
powerful I will say Wanda I think is the
only one that can like mess with reality
Maybe she might have a slight Ed because
of that what do you think what do you
think baby I am so scratched up all over
but it's
okay love Island I'm kidding I'm kidding
that's not true The Bachelor also
kidding maybe succession maybe stranger
things I would love to play Spider-Man I
used to play Spider-Man at kids birthday
parties and nobody ever believed that I
was Spider-Man so I feel like I feel
like maybe that'd be a good
one oh my God oh my God so many Ryan
Reynolds Hugh Jackman Merill stre Denzel
Washington Michael B Jordan Steven y
right aren't those good actors St and I
choose good
actors my favorite episode of Kim's
Convenience is is when I visit up in the
hospital it's the first time that we've
seen each other in such a long time and
we had this like really awesome moment
remember shooting the scene with Paul
Sun Young Lee who plays UPA and um it
was just so emotional it's such an
emotional moment for the both of us
wasn't it a fun
show I really love this place Fishman
Lobster Clubhouse it's about 30 minutes
out of the city oh my God think she's
following us Oh no you're still what's
going on what's going on whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa time's getting
a little rough over here guys you get
these massive towers of lobster drizzled
in like black bean sauce or like stir
fried with ginger scallion really oh in
my opinion the best way to have lobster
and um and there's no restaurant that
does it quite like
fish guys ow O that's a nibble ow ow ow
ow ow ow ow oh that's a hand that's a
hand my
love wa man uh one true loves is is a is
an amazing novel written by the
incredible Taylor Jenkins Reed and I was
lucky enough to play the character of
Sam was just shooting it actually we
just wrapped about a week ago in uh
Wilmington North Carolina it was just
such an incredible experience I really
got to delve into the character of Sam
and what I really love about him is is
his kindness there's a there's a
kindness and a generosity to him that I
don't think you see very often in
romantic leads and movies I think a lot
of times you know the male lead is like
this really aggressive guy or he'll
he'll make this like Grand gesture and
and and the you know the women are
always like oh my God you know but I
think what Sam does that nobody else
that is really special about him is that
he listens I'm really excited for people
to to watch
it I remember the the one thing I did
was I slid over the top of the bus I
swung around the side and I
I smashed into the door but we got that
in like a few takes I would say like the
hardest thing for me to do was trying to
manipulate the Rings and The Rings
weren't actually there so I had to like
try to F imagine trying to focus on
points in space that like were just not
there so they're like okay the Rings are
in front of you and now they're moving
around and it's just like weird because
your eyes can't focus on something
that's not tactile but somehow somehow
we found a way in the end we found a way
didn't we
guys
my go-to karaoke song is probably
Aladdin it's probably oh you want me to
what's you want me to sing it you want
going to sing it to you I can show you
the world oh shining Shimmer Rings
Blended Tell me princess that when did
you you're biting my face a ouch we were
asked to give a list of our of our
go-tos and and not all of them made it
but but thankfully that one did
my parents make the best dumplings in
the world period ow no argument it's
just it's just true I've had a lot of
dumplings from a lot of different places
and my parents are the best they have
the best
ones my favorite fan story is uh I was
shooting a movie in the Dominican
Republic I met one of the dog extras
that were on set and then I fell in love
and then I took her home with me I took
her home like someone's going to take
you home it's
true probably Superman I just love the
idea that he was kind of like an
immigrant in a way like even though he
was he was living among among humans
like he wasn't really from there and he
was constantly having to you know in
some ways hide who he really was I just
I think I related to that oh my God this
has been absolute
torture no it hasn't this is the best
hello I'm Brie Larsson and I will be
answering fan questions while playing
with
puppies hello
baby
hi wait more I get two three four four
oh my gosh no way come on join the party
baby want to sit in my lap hi little
angels
oh come back here baby uh I did have
hesitations because I was uh I didn't
know that I would do interviews with
puppies I didn't know that was part of
the contract I thought that
uh I was actually scared of this part of
the process the idea of like my face
being places and dealing with the sort
of like Fame stuff was not super
appealing to me cuz I uh am an introvert
so I needed to take a little bit of time
to see if I could kind of handle the
leadership position of this part but I
didn't have any issue with you know the
character the movie or what they were
trying to do with it in fact I was
really excited about which was why it
was kind of a difficult decision but um
I'm really glad I did it and it feels
like a like a giant wind for introverts
everywhere it was just a very simple
moment I was in a wardrobe fitting and I
didn't even know it was happening I had
tried on various pieces of the costume
and you kind of do like a fitting for
the boots A fitting for the pants
fitting for the top A fitting for the
helmet and so I didn't I didn't know
that I was finally going to put it all
on for the first time and it takes like
a couple people to put it all on and I
was talking and wasn't paying attention
and suddenly I looked in the mirror and
was like oh my gosh it looked like a
Disneyland character and then I just was
like really concerned about going to the
bathroom I'm also like a woman so I'm I
have a menstration and that was also
scary to me I was like what do I do how
do superheroes do this but they were
super awesome and had tons of extra you
know zippers and ways that I could get
out of it still takes like 30 minutes to
get out of it to go to the bathroom but
it's
[Music]
fine it impacted me in that it made me
from the very beginning I mean just
deciding to take on the rollment that I
was going outside of my comfort zone and
going to push myself to do things that
were I don't know things that I never
thought that I could do whether it was
deadlifting or learning martial arts
things like that those were all very new
for me I don't know I have no
expectations how it impacts people you
know I don't really I don't really know
I don't really feel like it's up to me
oh you came back you came back to me why
is that so satisfying I feel like
accepted and understood and seen oh
that's an expensive
[Laughter]
shoe H there's a couple things for
different reasons that were intense the
there's a ropes course scene in the
movie and we did that 50 ft up in the
air hair on
wires um I had to learn how to do these
like kind of like flip around wire kick
things that was pretty cool and new and
also like the the thing I think it's
like in the trailer I think people have
seen it now where I'm hanging on the
side of a train and I sort of pull
myself up and go into a shoulder roll
and then blast oh also the in the mind
Frack sequence when I'm hanging upside
down so I'm hanging uh by my ankles and
I have to you know use my abs to lift
myself up break the restraints and then
flip around and let and that took like
you know a solid weekend to learn how to
get
right uh I really am into butterfly
Clips I also keep thinking about hit
Clips I don't know if anybody else
remembers those but they were like 60
second like little microchips that you
could buy at McDonald's that played like
uh in sync and back stre boys I don't
know why I so badly want those to come
back cuz they're really not practical
but I like it
a real life role model was my mom for
sure and then like I love the Spice
Girls I loved Sailor Moon I'd like come
home from school just to try to not miss
a second of Sailor Moon I did read
Wonder Woman Comics growing up so maybe
some of that
[Music]
yeah I think I mean the flow toon blasts
are super cool but the more I think
about it the more I feel like flying is
probably like the most practical applic
I could use for my
life yeah I mean I don't even need to
cut it for a movie I would I've had my
hair that short before I kind of been
thinking about doing it to be honest
just because it's less
work I feel like at this point in my
life I'm probably the most like Carol
than anything but it's also just because
like she's such an empowering role
whereas I feel like most of the things I
did before were more dramatic and so
when those movies were done I was like I
can kind of leave that experience behind
but after playing Carol for close to a
year basically once it was all said and
done I I just I dig her vibe and I feel
like a lot of the way that she views the
world and in particular how she owns and
Views herself I think is is empowering
and helpful to me I've just decided to
be a little bit more like
[Music]
her I can tell you
nothing absolutely nothing uh so this
was me doing an interview while playing
with puppies and I wish it would never
end hi I'm Benedict come batch I'm here
at BuzzFeed and I'm here to play with
puppies and to answer your questions I'm
excited I'm excited to meet the pups
bring in the
pups hello you're a big puppy what are
we doing in here what a strange
environment to
be what was that noise what was that
noise okay what's in the job what's in
the J what's this what's this what's
this it's a question what's the best and
worst thing about playing doctor strange
um the best thing is yeah you eat that
question eat it up yeah yeah there's a
lot of best things about it best thing
is probably having a cloak that means I
can fly which means I get to do wire
work which when it's done right and not
for too long and a harness is incredibly
good fun some of the stunts are really
good fun to do the training and all of
that I really enjoy it's it's a big old
workout yes it is the worst thing
is I don't know it's a really gifted gig
I'm very lucky if I'm to moan about
something what would it be maybe maybe
the cloak again the cloak is quite
cumbersome no P intended hello um yeah
it can be quite a sort of awkward thing
to work with cookie jar no I'm joking
it's just it's it's questions I'm so
sorry do you still know how to play the
viin if so which do I still know I never
knew how to play the viin next question
it was all fakery and really
embarrassing you know this is something
that takes years of practice from the
age of three and then I'm supposed to
sort of turn it around in a couple of
months before doing a bit of Sherlock
not good my friends I can pretend to be
a lot of things with some degree of
authenticity but that is something Welly
on me uh who's the first real friend you
made in Hollywood and do you two still
speak I don't know I mean Gary Oldman I
guess yeah we still speak first time I
went to Hollywood I did Star Trek and I
don't speak to them nearly I mean Zoe I
see more of obviously because of the
Marvel thing but Chris I adore and and
you know and Zachary as well yeah it was
it was it was it is a great family was a
great family to be part of for a little
while there um and daring Anton as well
um who I wish I could still speak to
very sad don't eat my questions before
I've read them it's like having naked
flames in the room this is wonderful how
hard was it to jump back into your
normal life after playing a role like
Patrick MOS good question um difficult I
abstracted myself from my normal life
for a little while especially when I
went to the dark zone of um cocaine and
Heron abuse and trashing hotel rooms in
the New York episode just didn't really
want to go home with any of that selling
around my brain and body I mean not
literally but just psychically and uh
well and physically cuz you just have to
pretend and put yourself down it just
you need some space but most of the time
I I switch on and off pretty easily
which app on your phone do you use the
most probably
weighs hey go easy you may be bigger but
that's not playing Fair stop it stop it
yeah because I'm your own size no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no if you
could do film adaptation of any TV show
you loved as a child what would it which
one would it be why would I want to do a
film of something that worked well in in
it's time as a TV series I mean don't
get be wrong that happens a lot but
that's not really that's not my gig I
don't I'm not too fond of that stuff are
you ever going to join Instagram or
Twitter didada no absolutely not who are
your all-time favorite musicians which
present artist are you listening to
nowadays I don't have an all-time
favorite I mean Bowie the Stones The
Ramones sexist
Clash who Pink
Floyd what am I listening to at the
moment well elbows in your arm it's
great moonshape pool gets a lot of play
radio heads um I love Tom's new album as
well it's a very good film he did with
Paul Thomas Anderson I think so serus
whil your relative choose my boot want
my boot want
myot describe a perfect day hello this
is a perfect day isn't it getting my ear
licked by a puppy yeah this is pretty
perfect this is great but I mean the
rest of perfect with me would be it so I
won't describe it um work-wise though a
perfect day
is I I don't know I love my job pretty
much every day is a good one Perfect Day
is when I've had 8 hours sleep it's a
perfect day what are some of people pet
peeves oh God but people sound so
grouching when they answer these
questions I don't know people leaning on
their horn thinking it's going to make
traffic move faster people being trapped
in their bubble you know people being
trapped in their bubble full stop uh
mobile phone usage negative impact of
some of social media I mean I could go
on I'm an old fogy now 43 sufficient
good question I really could go on so I
will dirty tricks
demagogy uh fake news Everyone's a
Critic and angry but they don't
necessarily have any kind of nuance they
just want to shoot the messenger
sometimes not the message the fact that
we're in a crisis people a climate
crisis these little puppy dogs save the
puppies if not yourselves stop using
single use plastic try and stop digging
carbon fuels out of the ground please
leave the fossil fuels alone for these
puppies it's a dangerous question to
give me yeah can I have another pet PE
yeah burning rainforest what the is
wrong with the world uh what was it like
babysitting Tom hun during your MCU
press tour difficult like I said I had
to teach a kid how to shave how to brush
his teeth the fact you had to do it both
day and night um you know personal
hygiene is a bit of an issue with
teenagers and Tom's no exception to that
rule uh so you know I F get the rooms I
get out you know the kind of it was it
was tricky um but you know he's in all
instances he's a gentleman brilliant
wise Beyond his years uh tolerant to me
and a dear friend I love working with
him and bring on the next project
[Music]
goodbye